sébastien jumel il est le député gauche
démocratique et république de la 6e
circonscription de seine maritime et
voit dans ce projet la suite une vieille
doctrine libérale
on doit y voir une fois de plus les
vieilles doctrines libérales le
renoncement à assumer des prérogatives
d'état stratège j'ajoute que en se
débarrassant en ouvrant le capital privé
des énergies renouvelables et à se
privent d'outils qui lui permettent y
compris de lutter efficacement contre le
réchauffement climatique tant qu' on est
dans une logique qui vise à faire
plaisir à des actionnaires privés ou
concurrents d'edf et à s'inscrire dans
l'esprit du traité européen de
concurrence libre et non faussée
c'est purement idéologique même l'ancien
président d'edf monsieur broglio qui
n'est pas réputé pour être proche des
communistes considèrent que c'est une
erreur stratégique une erreur industriel
in heureux pour l'état souverain